hi everyone thank you for joining us
today on our webinar on seven tips for
motivating middle school and high school
kids during distance learning my name is
diane tiu and i'll be kicking us off
today as well as moderating our q a
portion of today's segment uh before we
get started there's a couple of
announcements i'd like to make
first of all this webinar is being
recorded and you will automatically be
emailed a copy of it as well we'll be
posting this online and available for
your review at your convenience so don't
worry if you miss anything or if you
want to go back and watch something
secondly we're really excited to
announce for the first time that we're
making this webinar available in spanish
captioning so
if you want you can go to
this bit the url it's also being entered
in our chat box right now so you can
click to that and the way you'll see it
is you'll don't close out of this
webinar you'll see still be watching
this webinar and that link will take you
to a captioning site where you'll see
the translations as we speak or as close
as close as possible as we speak
and we'd also like to thank several
organizations who've really helped us
with philanthropic support which has
enabled us to bring new programming like
today's session so we want to give a
special thanks to um att bank of america
google.org fastly and novartis
with that i'd like to introduce you all
to kristin diserbo who will be walking
through the tips and answering your live
questions kristen's our amazing chief
learning officer she's also an expert in
learning science and she's going to be
sharing all of her expertise with you
today so with that take it away kristin
great thanks dan and welcome to all of
you
thanks so much for joining
i know that
raising
teenagers is difficult
so one of the big jobs of a teenager
is to
differentiate themselves from their
parents
and to think about who they are outside
of their family and that means that
sometimes it's really hard to know
what's going on with them and they're
trying on new identities and they're
trying new things
so
i'm not going to tell you that i have
all the answers today sorry
but hopefully i can provide some
strategies that maybe you haven't
thought of before other things to try
um
ways that things things you might give a
chance to there's nothing that's going
to work for everyone there's nothing
that's going to work for every kid
but there's some things we can all think
about trying sharing and to to make
things a little bit easier for ourselves
so with that disclaimer i'll start off
i'm going to go through the
the tips that are based on
research and what we know
and then go and dan will ask some of the
questions that you guys are putting into
the questions piece on the
webinar and we'll have some time for q a
so with that
when you take all of the research about
motivation and think about okay what is
the what is the big thing what are the
big takeaways it turns out that it's
pretty simple
we're all motivated to do things
when one we expect to be successful at
them and two we value the activity so
this probably makes sense who wants to
do things when they think they're going
to fail at them or not be successful
and second we want to do things that
matter that are important to us now one
of the tricks with teenagers is that the
things they value are changing
and sometimes they're not communicating
the things that they value anymore and
so that can make it difficult to think
about how do you help then help them
increase their their perceived value of
an activity because it's not always
clear so i'm going to talk a little bit
more about ways to ways to use that
level of value
and also ways that we can help help our
our students feel like they're going to
be successful
so if we think about all of the rest of
the tips that i'm going to give they're
pretty much based on doing one or both
of these things
so if you keep that in your mind even if
these particular tips aren't working you
might think of other ways that you can
help students be successful or help them
really see value in the activities that
they're being asked to do in school
so one of the biggest things that hits
on both
value and success
is setting goals
and the reason it's related to success
is because nothing makes you feel like
you can be successful as having had some
success in the past so if you set some
short-term goals and students are able
to achieve those they start to gain
momentum they start to see themselves as
learners um and that can be really
important just in changing the mindset
so think about for for teenagers for
kind of
middle school and high school students
you don't want to set a goal that's
longer going to take longer than a week
because even at this age
more than a week is a long time to kind
of be able to move through so if you do
want to set like your goal for the month
or for the semester
you're going to want to break that up
into pieces so that it's something
that's that there's a tangible
achievement pretty quickly so you start
to get that feeling of success and build
that momentum
and the other piece you want to do is
find ways to know
if you're on track to meet that goal so
if you have a weekly goal say we're
going to try to read three chapters in
this book by the end of the week think
about what does that break down to per
day think about that's a way to monitor
progress so that then
they know are they on track oh i didn't
quite read that many pages yesterday so
i'm going to read this many today
or i'm going to read a few extra today
so i don't have to read as many tomorrow
those kinds of conversations are
important to help students build that
muscle of being able to
think about their own progress and
whether they're on track or not
so we want to keep when we're thinking
about setting goals we don't want to set
too many keep them you know a few not
more than three
so think about
short goals
a brief number of them and goals that
you can really measure so you know when
you've met them
which leads us to the next piece
celebrate success so
if students do meet their goal you want
to make sure that
that's a
big message that they're getting hey you
were successful
so that can be a variety of things it
can be your tone of voice when you're
talking about it it can be
uh you know high fives and hugs it can
be you know uh
choosing what's for dinner we're gonna
talk more about tangible rewards a
little bit later but he's thinking about
you know ways to celebrate when students
do meet their goals
and also take that as a time to reflect
so it's important when students are and
when they're not successful to think
about what were the things that helped
them meet that goal what did they do
that helped them be successful or what
were the obstacles that got in the way
so that they weren't successful and how
can they think about
what they might do differently next time
or what they're going to repeat next
time to be able to have success so that
little bit of reflection can be really
important for students too to be able to
get to that and both with setting goals
and reflecting you want to bring the
students in you don't want to be as a
parent setting the goal for them you
want to be working with them to set
goals and also in when we're talking
about school and learning a good idea to
connect with their teacher to look at
what their goals are that are already
set out by their teachers are so you can
make sure that that's all in lockstep
with where where students need to be
so
the other piece of reflection is
thinking about what happens
when what happened when they maybe ran
into trouble or got stuck a little bit
and that relates to the third tip is
helping to manage roadblocks
so
sometimes particularly with distance
learning students will get to a place
where they just don't know what to do
next
so they're you know they're stuck
and they don't know what to do
and then they get frustrated and it
starts to they get into this kind of
emotional spiral with it you want to
think about managing roadblocks before
they get to that point so when you were
talking about what are your goals for
the week that's the time to talk about
so what are you going to do when you get
stuck and they might even have you know
a little list of things that they can
refer to what to do when i get stuck how
do they get help from you if you are
available when they're working on their
their work i know lots of us are also
working from home at the same time so
what are the indicators that you have
when it's okay to ask you for help and
and hey when you're on a call and it's
not okay to ask for help like be really
specific about how to get help from you
how can they get help from their teacher
uh how can they find help online how can
we get help from their peers
so all of those things we should think
about what are the strategies that they
have when they get stuck maybe one of
the strategies is to walk away for a
little bit and come back that's a good
strategy especially when you start to
feel frustrated so think about how they
how to manage those those roadblocks
before they get in the situation of
needing to know how to what to do
from there
you want to think about emphasizing that
effort leads to success
so remember we talked about this idea of
feeling like you'll be successful but by
early teens
lots of kids already have some
perceptions of things they're just not
good at
and we want to make sure and try to
break those ideas that even when
we are not maybe quote naturally good at
something if we keep practicing at it
we'll get better
and we actually have on the count
academy website a course called growth
mindset and in that there are some
pretty good videos that talk about hey
not just saying hey you know keep trying
but the way our brains work there are
cells in our brains we call them neurons
and when we learn something new those
neurons form new connections with each
other
and so
what practice does and we even practice
when we're not succeeding even practice
that we're getting wrong helps build
those linkages and it's almost like when
you're
lifting weights and you can make this
analogy that your brain is a muscle
and when you're lifting weights
sometimes it's a little too heavy and
you can't quite lift that weight but you
go down a little bit and you practice at
that and it builds up your muscles the
same thing you practice at those
at that that level that's a little bit
hard for you
and your brain's going to make more
connections if you just practice same
with lifting weights if you're just
lifting the two pound weights and it's
not really hard for you
well you're probably not building your
muscles the same way if you're just
practicing stuff you already know that's
super easy you're not making those
connections in your brain so we find
that in the research that when kids
start to understand a little bit about
actually there's a biology basis for
trying things and working on things that
are kind of hard for you um that that
actually motivates them to think oh i
can be successful i can improve at this
thing that i'm doing
so recommend checking out some of those
videos but also thinking about how to
help your students see that things
aren't always easy and that learning
actually is hard work and that's okay
because if they put in the work they're
gonna get better at it
so
that's the fourth uh fourth piece
the fifth one is to incur encourage
curiosity and this can be tough in
particular with teens and and pre-teens
and thinking about you know all of a
sudden they're not interested in the
same things they used to be interested
in and so it can take some work to try
to figure out you know what what kinds
of things are they interested in now how
do we help keep them
thinking about i wonder how the world
works so
the the ways so one thing you can do is
model that kind of thinking
you know ask those questions out loud
ask those things like you know when
you're riding your bike why does
peddling the the pedal move the big
wheel um all of these kinds of things
how is this tree
you know not it doesn't seem to be
getting any food how is it you know
continuing to grow and what does that
look like so if you're asking those
questions and modeling and being curious
about the world
students will pick up on that to those
oh that is interesting and they'll start
to find things and it won't be
everything and sometimes they'll roll
their eyes
but
as you keep trying and keep putting
things out there different things and
they'll start to kind of oh maybe that
is interesting or start to have a
conversation about that or start to
build on that so keep encouraging that
sense of interest and curiosity in the
world because what this does is it
increases that value piece that i was
talking about so if learning in school
can help you understand the world and
help you understand things you're
curious about
then that's going to increase that value
and make you more motivated to do the
activities that that you're doing
related to school
so
that piece
the next piece is related to that which
is help establish relevance so if you
talk to teachers they will almost always
say
um
they hate the question when kids say
when will i ever need to learn this
but it turns out that when we again
think of that value side of the equation
that thinking about
how something is related to
your interests your goals what you might
want to be when you grow up related to
learning something else that you're
interested in learning
all of those things increase the value
of the activity and make students more
likely to want to engage in it
so those are important pieces to think
about
how do we establish that relevance so
this comes back to knowing what your
kids interests are
which can do involves some detective
work it can value observing them it can
involve talking to them all those
conversations sometimes they're not
going to want to talk but that's okay
keep keep going persistence on your part
is important too
and they will recognize that so
thinking about how to establish what is
relevant
um to your student to your kids um
you'll have to figure out what what are
their interests what are their things
that are important to them to be able to
help make those links but you have a
better chance of doing that than their
teacher does so
the more you can do that the
better impact you're likely to have on
their learning
so next then finally we talk a lot about
rewards and i got a lot of we get a lot
of questions from parents like is this
bribing my kid
i don't want to i don't want to bribe
them to do their work they should want
to do it those kinds of things so a
couple of a couple of pieces of guidance
one is we all use rewards uh i know i
use rewards for myself sometimes and i
think about you know when i
have to do a lot of writing and it's
kind of going slowly i'll say you know
if i just finish this page i'll have i
can give myself a hershey's kiss like
just a little piece of chocolate not a
big reward but a little something that's
a reward for doing it we're not all
intrinsically motivated to do everything
all the time sometimes we need a little
bit of boost and so rewards are used
and are best used when they're something
that we can
take and get students going on a path so
if it's something they don't have any
interest in doing a reward can be that
little boost that gets them started and
once they get started they can start to
again experience some success they can
start to find out interesting things
they can start to see themselves as
learners but they need that little boost
to get going so rewards can definitely
help do that
they also don't have to be tangible
things they can be like spending
you know time with you they can be
spending time with their friends they
can be
you know an extra half hour on the
computer playing the video in the game
they're interested in they can be
picking the movie it can be um you know
picking what's for dinner all kinds of
things can be rewarding that don't have
to be you know a tangible something that
is money related to cost and buying
things so think about using rewards to
get things going keep them small
help student help you can brainstorm
with your kid about what
rewards what things are rewarding to
them
um and that can be good to come up with
a you know a continuum of rewards if you
if your your student says yeah trip to
disney world
that can be on one end it can go on the
way bottom of the list but i'm not going
to encourage using those kinds of big
rewards they really are not effective
because they require you know the hey if
you get a's all year
you can get this
it's just too long of a timeline and two
too big of a stakes
so you want to do small things so if
they don't get it
then that's okay because they'll have
another chance which is the final thing
about using rewards is it shouldn't be
something they either earn or they have
no chance of ever earning again it
should be okay if you didn't earn it
this time
we can set a new goal and you can try to
earn it again the next time
so you want to think about things that
are um you know have are small and able
to if they don't make it the first time
are able to try again to earn those
things
so those are some of the big
tips and ideas for
thinking about um generally again
thinking about this balance of how can
we help kids
think they'll be successful and how can
we help them value the activities we're
asking them to do
so i will stop and pause there and dan
uh
ask you to
to give us some of the questions we
heard
yeah great so thanks kristen uh before
we get into the q a portion a couple of
reminders for folks if you want a
handout version of this and go to
webinar there's a handout section with a
link to this pdf with these seven tips
um and then also we are already getting
a lot of great questions but if you have
any questions please put them in the
question box there's a team of
moderators kind of behind the scenes
putting in
all the questions and surfacing them up
so go ahead and start entering them
right now
so kristin we already had a couple of
questions come in uh one from email from
a couple of days ago a question is from
the person s
um how do we get our older kids not to
play games on their school issued
devices without police policing them
constantly it's a huge distraction and
very difficult to control we already
have contacted the school several times
about about blocking some of these sites
it's still an issue i mean i would
assume for younger kids it's probably
minecraft for the middle kids it's
probably fortnight and then now it's the
among us game right so there's this
all this constant uh distractions that
are available for the kiddos
oh my gosh i just uh saw the congress
people playing among us the other day
wow that was crazy um
so
there's a couple of things here
absolutely one of the challenges of
learning from home
is that there are so many more
distractions
um and that it can be really difficult
to uh to think about okay how do we help
kids focus
so
there's a couple of ways to
to kind of attack this issue one is if
i'm gonna i'm gonna keep hitting on this
goals piece um if they have goals that
are set so that this is what they need
to achieve
then
they we want to work with them to make
sure they're on track to do that
then they'll
think about okay if i'm doing this
does that get me off track to meet the
thing that i need to do i need to read
30 pages today
all right can i read 15 and then play a
little bit and then read 15 more like
have these kind of conversations with
them about how they might still be able
to play some if the playing is allowed
at all on the device side there's a
couple of different ways this might be
going this question could be going like
if the games are not allowed on the
devices you probably need to think about
those technological solutions that block
them um but if if gaming's allowed but
they need to be doing their schoolwork
think about how you can potentially set
up schedules that let them have some
game time like have a little bit of game
time have breaks breaks are good we all
need breaks
and then they need to come back from the
break and think about continuing their
school
and their work and what those are those
can be you know good ways to think about
teaching moderation um thinking think
about teaching a little bit of that you
know kind of control of what they're
doing set the timer for however you know
15 minutes that they can play
and then come back to doing what they're
doing can
think about what that is they've also
told you this is a really rewarding and
interesting thing for me so if you can
think about how to use that as a reward
and turn it into a reward you know that
that's something that they're probably
going to work for because that's where
it is and how they're getting there i'm
gonna
you know it probably any other kind of
you know punitive measures and all of
that are not gonna be that successful
it's more like turning up the dial on
some of the school work and letting them
have the game uh you know pieces of the
game at different times when it's
appropriate and help them figure out how
to make a schedule that fits into to
help those work
so they can play a little bit yeah
that's super helpful i love the
suggestion of turning it into part of
the incentives piece
um kristen we have a question from nan
who's who asks um it's related to the
goal so once after you've kind of
figured out the goal the question is how
do you convince the kid that achieving
the goal will lead to success um a lot
of the times the kids don't don't
believe you
so
one thing is to set up meeting the goal
itself is success like the
if you're gonna you know again
you're going to try to do
um you know 35 practice problems
on um
factoring polynomials
that's an except like meeting that goal
itself like doing 35 practice problems
and meeting polynomials
that is a success in itself that's great
so the the
you want to make that itself an end
point for them like that's really good
that they've done that um so it's that
that piece that
then makes them feel like hey so next
week
the math
challenge is going to be you know adding
and subtracting polynomials but
now you already were successful at
factoring them so it's really likely
that you're going to be successful at
adding and subtracting them because you
already were successful once on this
other thing that was pretty hard to
learn and you did it
so the the key is to use kind of their
past successes and their successes once
they they in themselves are success and
then using those to build on those of
why they're likely to be successful in
future things
that's great that's great um kristen we
have a question from arlene um and the
parents asked a question i think a lot
of us have experienced um one i'm a
parent of a high schooler and a middle
school counselor a lot of our students
are struggling with depression and
anxiety from being in the house since
last march they're not motivated and
upset because they're failing how can we
motivate them when they're mostly upset
from being in the house for six plus
months i think it's just really
important to recognize that that's a
that's pretty normal i mean i know that
i've experienced a little bit of that
too during these last you know eight
months
absolutely
so the first thing i'm going to say is
that mental health is more important
than school
progress
so
the
first thing i would say is
think about
as you said dan some amount of just
being
mildly depressed and a little bit
anxious is pretty normal in these these
kinds of times
if you're finding that it seems to be
beyond a little bit if it's really
interfering with their interactions with
your family if it's really interfering
with their just daily lives like they
are not getting out of bed um you know
real those kinds of signs
i i absolutely recommend professional
help um
you know talk to your pediatrician is a
good starting point make sure to you
know think about what are the signs of
you know someone who's who's needing
who for whom this is a little bit more
than oh this is tough um
so that's the first thing i would say is
know when to get help um there's
a number you know lots of good ways to
check it but the as a what psychologists
usually look for is when it starts to
interfere with your daily life as kind
of a good rule of thumb for when it
makes sense to get help
but if it is like less than that and
it's hey you know i just am sad today
i'm just feeling anxious today
all of those things so first as a parent
just empathize
just like dan just did hey you know what
i get it this situation is no fun like
all of us are struggling and i it is
totally okay to struggle um i also
encourage
you know the way this was written was
being in the house it does help if
you're in a place even if it's
um not with other people to at least get
some
outside air to go out and and move and
um get some get some fresh air if that's
possible where you live and in your
weather and all those kinds of things um
the next piece is that exercise piece
like moving can be important and can
help kids get up so even if they're if
you're thinking about the school day
they should have breaks in their school
day where they are getting up and moving
and walking and and i i'm saying this as
do as i say not as i do i'm the worst
that i've been sitting in my chair here
for like eight hours um but thinking
about getting up and moving is okay
and you know making sure some of that's
built in and the final thing that teens
really struggle with i think is the peer
interaction and the
the reduced care interaction they've had
in these times so if there are ways that
you can help facilitate
um whether that's online
you know video interactions whether
that's um if you have you know a small
safe group um i know some people are
doing hey there's two other families
that we all you know
have kind of the same view on what's
acceptable in terms of safety and um and
we all get together you know finding
some ways that kids can connect with
other kids
can be helpful too in these times that
we found so
lots of different potential things but
um
empathize definitely you know talk to
your kids about it
make try to keep those doors open so
that they can talk to you when they have
concerns
great advice thanks kristin
um we have a question from um barbara
who's asking advice for kids who strive
for perfection who are super motivated
but they are also um they kind of are
worried about doing things that are
imperfect and that experience in itself
overwhelms them um so how do how do you
help those students um i think some of
the compartmentalizing and making things
more chunkable that you talked about
earlier was super super relevant for
this type of case as well
yeah definitely thinking about um
how to you know
think about what is
uh what is done what is acceptable on
for an assignment um what is okay and
the other piece is to really try to
focus on
learning as opposed to grades so one of
the things that often happens with kids
who kind of have that perfectionist
streak is they really start to focus on
getting a hundred or you know getting
really that perfection piece and tr the
what you want to try to do is to turn
that focus to what did you learn today
what are the new skills you have what
are the new ideas you understand and
asking
the more you can ask questions about
those things and start to try to
celebrate learning something new or
getting a new skill or being able to do
something you couldn't do before and
trying to get them to focus on that
piece as opposed to the
you know what was your grade or score on
this can be helpful in in reducing some
of that
um perfection piece
and the other the other um
thing i would say is to you know
uh try to communicate that failure is
okay and failure is actually how we
learn that gets back to some of that um
that growth mindset communication that
it's okay
to not be successful sometimes that
helps us learn
um and you know trying to help kids be
okay with that and interestingly for all
the talk about games games are actually
pretty good at teaching that
that you know it's okay to fail and you
end up you can get your lives back you
can start over um it's all it's all okay
but kind of communicating about that
idea can be important too for kids
nice um great great kristen
one question we have from dennis who's
asking remote learning's a big part of
this year's curriculum um this uh this
allows for different routines in the day
you know some days it's work from home
some days uh the kids can work
you know stay in their pajamas and take
some classes um what advice would you
have or how much emphasis would you say
in maintaining a consistent routine
versus you know altering the routine
yeah so good question
kids generally do thrive on routine um
and knowing what to expect and what's
going to come next
but that doesn't mean it has to be
always
the exact same thing
so what i would advise in terms of
maintaining is maintaining a
a you know schedule so at nine o'clock
this happens at 10 o'clock this happens
that's written down is usually helpful
with some visual cues so they can take a
look at it and really you know reference
okay here's what's coming next here's
what's what's coming up today for the
rest of the day
and um so if that part is maintained
like they know what's coming then you
can flex a little bit like other things
like what are they wearing
it's okay if they're gonna you know
think about hey and you can think even
schools do this if you remember back to
when your kids were in elementary school
they probably did you know it's crazy
hat day
it's pajama day
um all of those things are good good
flexes to make in the routine so it
doesn't just become monotonous
and there's new things that they're
doing
i will say you also talked about classes
lounging on the futon
i i have mixed feelings about that
it's good if kids have a space to learn
that's kind of signals to them mentally
i'm on now
because as we were talking about all
those other distractions if you're kind
of trying to do school in the same place
that you hang out and play video games
at night in the same place that you know
you're watching movies that's kind of
not communicating hey now's the time i
need to
kind of tell my brain it's time to focus
on school work so the more you can in
terms of the place have some kind of a
step place that is you know
communicating to them this is where the
the school work happens is probably a
good idea
but you know one class lounging on a
futon one you know video isn't gonna
isn't gonna hurt anyone
i love that i know for myself personally
i've been in this room for eight months
and then i think once a month i decide
to go to like the kitchen or the dining
room and try to change things up just
just a little bit
yes yes absolutely we have a follow-up
about the rewards and incentives so kiki
asks i've used fortnight as a reward in
the past
but um they find that
that my son rushes through his work in
order to quickly get to playing this
game
so how do you get him to understand that
it's not just the quantity but actually
the quality of the work that is
important
yes well the reward has to be contingent
on the quality
so the reward can't just be doing the 10
math problems it has to be doing the
attend math problems and maybe
explaining to you why they're right if
it's depending i know some math problems
right now there's probably some math
problems i couldn't grade like i
wouldn't know if they were right or
wrong
you know some pre-calculus problems and
things um
and so if it's the case where you
actually aren't sure if they're right or
wrong
have that have your student explain them
to you and walk you through the steps
and if he can do that then he can play
um so it's definitely a matter of trying
to set that goal for quality if it's
something that you can look at and see
if he's met a quality standard great if
not have them explain it to you and see
if they've met that that kind of
standard
now that's great i think this is one
challenge that i remember as a kid you
know you have to finish your homework
before you get to do you know play with
your friends and you would just go home
and rush through your homework just to
just go play with your friends right
absolutely absolutely so there has to
they i know this puts burden on parents
to say you've got to check it a little
bit but
if you're thinking about rewards you
kind of do otherwise you're going to get
those unintended consequences
so kristen i think we have time for
maybe one or two more
we have a really good question from
ranga
these recommendations require parents to
constantly engage throughout the day
otherwise the children go back to
playing you know whatever they like
um how do you
how are you
kind of constantly engaged i think this
posits a question where um i don't i
don't know if you do have to be
constantly engaging i think um you know
the assumption here is that that you
have to be
kind of with your child the whole time i
think part of your recommendations it
allows you to free up some of that time
so can you speak to um how do you kind
of balance the engagement and the time
that as a parent you have to do your
your day job
yeah
so first just let me recognize that it's
absolutely
we're asking
way too much of parents right now we are
asking them to do you know multiple jobs
and uh not giving any
you know break on the amount of time
needed to do them
um but i do think that what you want to
do is think about how you can structure
the day
so that they have set things they're
supposed to do at set times
and then you can do check-ins to see if
they got those done and so the and again
you want to think about positive
reinforcement so you may have to start
off with some very small chunks
but over time you can gradually extend
them
so if you're thinking about you know
at the beginning you may need to say
okay here's what we're gonna do in the
next hour
and if we get that done
then you set the goal for the next hour
so that would require like hourly
check-ins um but over time as they you
know start to again see okay what's our
goal for the next two hours
and again
using rewards is not a bad thing
think about how you can reward
meeting those goals that you set for
those short time periods and then
lengthen them over time so that you
don't have to check in um so frequently
and they're still
getting that feeling of success and
staying on task
so i think we have time for one more and
we have a couple of questions around the
same theme which is from linda and
annika you know they're both wondering
um what ideas do you have to for
students who sees you know zero value in
school or
if uh they
their the kids desire to fit in socially
causes them to kind of digress
academically
yeah they're probably a bit separate but
um
so
if your kid is really motivated by
social things you want to think about
how to tie social things into learning
how to provide social learning
experiences
um you know are there small study groups
even if the you know the two kids are
just on their
computers and have the video on but
aren't studying together there's just
like some social interaction there um
can you think about you know having them
access to peers as something that's
rewarding for them um
so find ways to give them that social
experience but tie it into also
learning goals and being able to learn
together with their peers and what
they're doing
so that's kind of the social piece the
other piece for kids who just don't see
a value of school is that you know the
toughest thing about teenagers is
probably for those who it's tough to
figure out what they are interested in
but that's my advice is to figure out
what what does interest them what are
the things that
they
value what are the things that are
interesting to them is it you know
working on old cars is it you know
baking what are the things what is
something that they like to do and then
think about how you can tie in things
they're learning in school
to
that piece of things i use baking a lot
i
because it's easy to set up
there's a lot of math and baking and you
can you know kind of make some of those
ties in there but there's the the key is
to think about what are the things that
are interesting and trying to make those
links whether it's future careers
whether it's learning something that
helps them be better at that thing that
they're doing um relating their physics
lessons to things that are going on
whatever that is that they're interested
in um
it is
and it can be tough to figure out
sometimes teenagers can seem pretty
apathetic about a lot of stuff and don't
want to show their parents when they're
interested in things
um but
the
it so it again put on your detective
hack um so you can figure out what it is
that that they are interested in start
to try to build some of those bridges
yeah that's wonderful um unfortunately
that's all the time we have for
questions today and so kristin thank you
for sharing your expertise with with our
audience and we want to thank you all
all the busy parents out there we know
it's an incredibly busy time and you're
balancing a lot so we want to thank you
for joining our session today a couple
of reminders if you miss anything or you
want to review by registering for this
webinar you'll automatically be um
emailed this recording
if you want to download the pdf as well
that'll automatically be sent to you and
we will we also be posting this in
youtube uh afterwards as well so you'll
have multiple chances to go back and
look at some of the um the content if
you missed anything and then secondly we
have a lot of resources available on our
keep learning dot khan academy
dot org microsite which has all of our
distance learning uh materials in one
place
and then before we wanna before we sign
off we want to ask you to do two things
for us um first you know there's a poll
that will pop up and we will be asking
you how could we make future iterations
of this session uh more useful for you
and then secondly we will ask you you
know your advice on what kinds of
sessions would you like to see us uh
build on next so plea please let us know
um this is was actually a result of some
of your feedback in the past as well and
we're totally here to support you in any
way we can
so from all of us at khan academy thank
you again for joining us and have a
great great evening